this is 15 thousand year-old glacial
water in this bunker the age of Jesus my
name is Martin Riza and I'm the water
summer yet now I'm the only certified
water swimmer gig in America I hope
you're thirsty I immediately was like
where do you get a degree in water what
does somebody is a person who likes to
be hydrated and honest water in a
slightly different way I think I wanted
to create a water menu in 2005 then in
2010 I wrote a book about water in 2011
I've been certified as a water sommelier
from the German water trade association
and then I came over in 2011 as well
here to Los Angeles based on an o1 visa
for extraordinary abilities because I
can drink water Vichy Carolyn is very
famous in Spain this is the number one
consumed Spanish sparkling water before
coming in today like I was thinking to
myself like I'm sure I couldn't even I'm
not gonna be able to tell the difference
but they're like Vichy Carolyn has
strong reactions because people think
it's very very salty I love her that's
his thing you put like a spoonful of
thought in this water this is not yes
this has over a thousand milligrams of
sodium
why so this waters might be very
offending in the beginning but it pairs
perfectly - very very strong dishes like
steaks and barbeque Wow
pairing that with the meat and the
prosciutto like it completely changed it
yeah I like it it evens out the
saltiness of this and this evens up the
next one is Roy from Slovenia this is
$56 per pot 56 liver-lips dollars per
bottle 56 bucks more a bottle some
borders can be very expensive because
they're coming from a very very unique
spring so it says the world's most
magnesium rich water but something's
very breeding on this planet again we
are the only people right now in America
who have access to it
[Music]
that is water I'm happy with his
knowledge for me to know what I think
this tastes like to our consultants it
tastes like I also think that I'm gonna
be harder on this bottle because it's
$50 so I'm gonna be like mm-hmm that's
not even the most expensive one I have
let's taste the hundred and fifty dollar
water
this is fifteen thousand year old water
oh I don't deserve this
oh my god I'm eating shells a lot of
this yeah I want the luxury stuff oh
yeah I like this this is clean
I like this water I like it too wow that
water was like the cleanest water of all
time for me I completely understand that
some people will say this guy is
completely nuts and crazy with his
German accent and tells me that water
has taste but trust me just taste it for
yourself
bottled waters are their two big
differences one purified water nothing
else than actually tap water filtered
and adding back some electrolytes or the
waters where I brought this is actually
mother nature's water and I always
believe water should come from nature
and not from a factory this is nothing
like on a daily base yeah on a daily
basis go with your feet go with your
arrow head for examples equate water you
said we should get those it doesn't need
to be expensive at all so therefore it's
not just for the rich people and this is
very important for me as well because I
strongly believe water should be
accessible to every single person on
this planet water is a human right we're
living on a planet who gets warmer and
warmer every day so we need to change
our habits I think a little bit about
water we need to realize that water is
not just water without water we wouldn't
be here without water no life would be
on this planet
so let's value water let's give water
value and we should all honor water for
what it is the most important beverage
in our lives all where other experience
was just super cool I mean like I drink
water a lot it makes sense for me to be
careful with my choice of waters and the
most important thing for me guys is stay
thirsty
[Music]